[Music]
hello YouTube just love us in my friends
this is guns in here welcome to my 60th
episode of dirty chest tricks in this
episode I am going to show you one of
the modern tricky line against a peer
defense from the white perspective the
opening arises after the falling water
Evo d6 d4 Knight to f6 Knight to c3 and
now the trademark move g6 where black
has a simple intention to play the move
Bishop to g7 Castle and then hit back
white center with some nice counter play
now against this white has tried various
responses such as Bishop to e3 Knight to
f3 and even the space gaining new f4 but
I'm going to suggest this very nasty
move Bishop to g5 so idea is very simple
if allowed then white will definitely
take this Knight and give black a double
pawn so obviously Bishop to g7 is
obvious choice but after this here comes
the move with sets of the tricky
platform and that is e 5
hahaha and I bet black players eyes will
literally lit up as they can exchange on
Aoife and then trade the Queen which
obviously favors the black but the
matter of fact is the reverse is true
now before we look at the main line with
D captures Aoife the important point I
want to highlight here that if your
opponent continue with Knight F to d7
then white can simply respond with f4
and with the space in the center
the bishop is outside the pawn chain
this position always favors the white
camp so nope why should black goes for
this where he can easily capture on
Aoife and destroy a whole white
advantage in the opening stage well
believe it or not but this is exactly
what we want as after D captures ePHI
the tricky platformed sets up right here
now as we attacking the knight Black has
three major options but first let's look
at the obvious one Queen captures d1
rook captures vivillon and now the
obvious move Knight to g4 which to the
naked eye looks like winning the pawn
and yes indeed that pawn is lost except
black is losing the game outright
after this move White has the star mu in
this position h3 and now by force we are
getting the completely winning advantage
the first trap which many people fall
into this and that is Knight captures
ePHI which is outright blunder as after
the whites next reply yup you guessed it
Knight to d5 and no matter how River
black rigours he is going to lose the
exchange just within ninth move of the
game if the knight goes to a six then we
will obviously chop it off and if the
King comes on the D file let's say King
to d7 then we have this nice move Knight
to b6 which by force get the exchange
and in fact the game so this is one of
the high profile trick exist if your
opponent goes for Knight to g4 line
the second alternative night F to d7
doesn't change the scenario as this time
around we will still continue with night
to defy attacking on a two-week sport a
7 as well as c7 well you might think but
what about Bishop captures ePHI
defending on c7 but here comes the
second trick on the table as after
Knight to f3 this bishop is a completely
overload piece and he has to go to the
only square namely d6 in order to
protect the c7 pawn but now comes the
second dazzling trick on the table can
you spot it yup that is wonderful
Bishop captures c7 ahaha
so that means this bishop can now no
longer protect on c7 and after the
following forcing sequence Bishop
captures a seven-night capture c7 check
King to d8 and Knight captures 8 again
white emerge with an exchanger up and
blacks only hope to trap that night in
the corner with b6 completely fails due
to the falling water Knight to e5
looking at juicy folk on f7 so in the
database a game between 2 mm plus rated
opponent continue with rook to a fade
but this is turn out as a big time
disaster as after Bishop to c4 White has
multiple choices to save the knowledge
and Bishop to b7 completely faced due to
the following tactic Knight captures d7
Knight captures d7 and now the winning
shot Bishop to b5
which conforms white advantage as after
Bishop to see it and the MU castle the
easiest plan in the world is you can
play the move rook to d3 double up the
room and show your exchange advantage to
the black camp so if you open and tempt
it for the queen capture Steven then
writing a straightaway on the wall for
the black camp now apart from Queen
captures even black has tried other
options but they are not good either
for example if he continued here with
Knight to g4 which has the same
intention to capture on e5 well guess
what this is even worst than Queen
captures Devin has now white get chance
to exchange the Queen and then play this
nice sequence rook to d1 check if Bishop
to d7 then a6 is a very strong reply and
I have attached a sample line in the PGN
talking to e8 but that allow us to
simple execute what we have seen earlier
yup h3 and after Knight captures if I
and the move Knight to defy again and
again we are getting the exchange in a
broad daylight last but not least what
happens if you open and continue with
Knight F to d7 well this time around
White has this nice polliver namely a6
attacking to spot so black responses
force black has to capture on e6 and now
you have the target and the way to
exploit is to play this simple
continuation Quint we to attacking on e6
chess engine suggests that black should
play the Musa fire and give up the e6
which doesn't help the black cause so as
a human perspective
let's see what happens if black hold on
to his extra pollen and I just like to
show you one of my quickest win in this
line where my two thousand rated
opponent continued with Knight to f6
defending on e6 and also stopping me to
castle on the Queen side but this makes
things worse for the black cam as after
rook to d1 attacking the Queen Black has
to block with the bishop in order to
protect the e6 now I continue with
Knight to f3
so another threat Knight to e5 and then
nabbing the bishop so my opponents top
this with Knight to c6 but white keep
creating the threat with Knight to e4 so
the idea is very simple
either Knight to c4 or in some lines
white can exchange on f6 well my
opponent figure out that that Knight is
too strong so he chopped it off but that
just increase my piece development with
Queen captures a fool and after castle
and the move Bishop to c4 believe it or
not black get a completely lost position
well my careless opponent played the
last blunder of the game as he continued
with Queen to see it getting out of the
pin as well as defending on e6 but just
one move and black resign do you spot it
yup the dazzling blue rook captures d7
boom and black can't even touch this
rook as after Bishop captures c6 he will
lose his queen
that's it guys I hope you enjoy and
learn this amazing tricky line against
the pier defense remember once the black
exchange of an ephah no matter however
he continued it is white who decayed the
game from the opening stage thank you
for watching this video feel free to
like subscribe and comment and I will
meet you in my next episode very soon
bye and take care